this is a new Intel Arc a580 which was
launched last month at
$179 price so let's test it and see if
it's worth it hit the like button and
let's start I got mine from Amazon for
$179 and it is a sparkle Arc a580 OC
Edition I'm definitely happy to see
something new on a budget side in the
box we have a voucher code for two games
that's nice and the GPU itself it is a
very nice looking dual fan GPU with a
thick heat sink and metal back plate
feels very solid on the back we have a
free display port 2.0 that supports up
to 8K 60 HZ and 1 HDMI 2.0 TDP is 175
wat so it's a pretty power hungry card
and it requires the whole 2 8 Pin
connectors that's pretty rare for a
budget card so have to make sure you
have a good power supply I'm going to
pair this card with an Intel i5 11400 I
have 16 GB of RAM clocked at 4,000 MHz
and the whole Feld is powered by 650 W
power supply PC booted right away with
no problems we have a sparkle logo on
the GPU that lights up and it switches
different colors depending on GPU
temperature that's nice the first thing
after adding a new GPU is to get a
driver and for that I downloaded the
driver tool from Intel's website the
rest was pretty intuitive after all
updates are done I have an Intel R
control app open this is my first
experience with Intel's GPU and I got to
say the app looks great it's simp simple
and intuitive with all the features most
users would ever need from performance
monitoring to streaming let's quickly go
through the GPU specs it is a PCI E 4.0
card with 8 GB of gddr 6 memory 256bit
memory bus the max GPU clock is 2,000 MZ
this card also supports direct X12
ultimate so no problem running new games
av1 encoding for your production work
and Intel xcss support the key
competitors for this card are am MD Ron
RX 6600 which you can find for around
$200 for a while now this card is the
best choice in terms of price to rock
gaming performance and from idia we have
RTX 3050 which usually cost around
$220 let's now check the rock gaming
performance we get with a580 in 3D Mark
we are scoring 10,300 points that's not
bad GPU temperatures stayed under 70°
all the time moving on to games Intel
claims this is a card for high graphics
1080p game gaming so let's start from
low demanding online games inv valerant
with high settings getting over 200 FPS
most of the time with a Great Frame time
in CS2 with high settings getting stable
at around 130 FPS all the time while
testing CS2 I get a strange issue where
the image suddenly freezes and pixelates
I suspect it has something to do with
the monitor but not sure this happened
only in CS2 moving on to more demanding
online games Apex Legends on competitive
settings runs with with an FPS range
from 70 to 120 depending on this team
the game runs pretty smoothly with no
freezes in war zone 2.0 I see 70 to 80
FPS most of the time with the low
settings I'm getting micro freezes
sometimes but overall pretty stable in
fortnite with high preset getting 80 to
100 FPS most of the time with some drops
to around 70 in loaded scen in pubg with
high preset getting stable around 120
FPS you can see this card is not very
power efficient it's pulling around 150
WS right now also notice the GPU
temperature heating almost 70° and
that's with a side panel off this card
is going to get pretty hot in small PC
cases with low air flow anyway as you
can see it handles online gaming just
fine let's now move to more demanding
single player games in cyber Punk
Benchmark getting 64 average FPS with
high preset would' like slightly more
minimum FPS but the game is definitely
very playable moving on Elden ring on
maximum settings run runs at stable 60
FPS all time God of War also runs great
with high preset IC FPS in range from 60
to 75 in Starfield to get at least the
console 40 to 60 FPS range I had to
select low preset but the game still
looks pretty good in the new ghost
Runner 2 with a high preset gaining over
100 FPS I see freezes sometimes but
overall the game is playable I wasn't
using any upscaling for the testing so
judging by raw gaming performance I can
say this card can provide good FPS in
most games these days but I also think
it's not really future prooof for the
newer AAA titles you will have to count
on game optimization or on Intel xss
support which is an upscaling feature
that you can use to get more FPS moving
on to production and creativity tasks
this card has some real advantages
thanks to av1 Hardware encode and the
Intel XE media engine those can come in
handy when it comes to video production
software like Adobe also av1 encoding
will help you to record or stream your
games with better quality than any other
GPU in this budget so I think it is
definitely worth considering this card
with the price of $180 it provides great
performance for production work like
video photo editing and it won't
disappoint you in games either let me
know what you think about this card in
the comments below and I'll see you in
the next
video